Speaker 1: A former gas station manager in
California is out of a job right now after
making the mistake of selling premium gasoline for
$0.69 a gallon instead of $6.99 a gallon. The man
in question is name's John Suzanna, and he worked
at a Shell station in Rancho Cordova, California.
Once customers realized that there was a
mistake, they flooded to the gas station. And
what didn't, you know, they were totally willing
to take advantage of that 90% discounted gasoline.
I'm surprised they didn't show up with buckets and
everything else. They could store that gas because
prices for gasoline right now are at record
highs, especially over in California, $7 plus
per gallon. You'd think that they would try to do
all they could. But the problem is obviously that
nothing comes for free. And this was a small,
independently owned gas station and ultimately
there were about $20,000 in losses that resulted
from all of this. Susanna said about this, quote,
Once I realized what was going on, I immediately
thought we had been robbed. And I was scared that
something terrible had happened to the cashiers.
He was unfortunately fired over this mistake,
and he said about it, quote, Even though it cost
me my job, it's fine. Because the truth is, you
know, it was my fault. So he's definitely in good
spirits over this. And you can't help but feel
bad for this guy. Everyone makes mistakes, right?
Everyone types in the wrong number here and there.
Everyone will put in a typo. And for this guy,
it just happened to result in $20,000 in losses
for his company. Now, for most people, that's
where the story would end. But in John's case, it
actually continued because his sister felt so bad
about it that she decided to set up a go fund me
to help the newly unemployed John make up the
lost funds to his former employer. The Go Fund
Me was hugely successful. It surpassed the
$20,000 mark that they were trying to raise,
actually reaching and surpassing $24,000. John
sister said about this, quote, He doesn't have
to pay it back. But just the fact that he is
doing it and wants to do it shows a lot of
character and honesty and responsibility. And I'm
really proud of him for that. You got to wonder,
how can this guy stay fired, right? Like,
for one, this was an honest mistake, which
I understand. Sometimes people can get fired for
honest mistakes. Honest mistakes can kill people,
or they can, as in this case, cost a company
$20,000. But then even after all of that,
he didn't become a disgruntled former employee
like most people would do in that circumstance.
No, he raised the money not to pay for
his own living expenses, but to pay back
his former employer and then some. Right.
Because he actually raised $24,000.
So if anyone deserves their job back, it's this
guy. Maybe if he's not able to get the job back at
the gas station, we'll have to talk to David about
hiring him at the show because this is exactly the
type of commitment and character that we want in
an employee here. And if he makes another mistake,
if he makes like a typo for us, well, it's
probably just going to result in a YouTube
title being mislabeled and we'll have to go in
and fix it. It's not going to likely result in
us losing $20,000. So this is maybe not the most
important story, but I thought that with all this
craziness surrounding gas prices, it would be an
interesting one to bring to your attention today.